[Musique]
bienvenue chez audace je pensais que
Xavier cossat gérant de cette
chocolaterie artisanale on est situé à
La Possession on est ouvert depuis deux
ans
donc du chocolat noir réunion fait avec
du cacao de la réunion du Criolo 100 %
Criollo donc une variété rare ou un
chocolat blanc aux femmes de la réunion
qui a d'ailleurs été privé au chocolate
international World chocolat roux aussi
très gourmand
un chocolat au lait avec du Criolo
toujours qui lui confère vraiment une
spécificité un petit goût vraiment très
sympa pour les amateurs de chocolat au
lait et la version encore plus gourmande
avec des cacahuètes torrées la
spécificité de mes produits c'est
essentiellement du travail avec des
produits océan indiens exclusivement
également une démarche
raisonnée sur tout ce qui est emballage
donc vous le verrez on a pas d'aluminium
sur nos tablettes en la réussite à faire
des emballages qui sont compostables
faire découvrir tout le terroir à un
Lyonnais ainsi que une première démarche
je l'espère à l'export trouver des
contacts pour pouvoir enchaîner par la
suite et continuer à faire découvrir en
métropole de vos produits de la région
[Musique]